- I'm talking, everybody
needs to hear this.
This is "Crush It" 2008.
I was right, it's real.
People are still not doing it.
(yelling)
You got your perspective.
(audience cheering)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(chill music)
Hey guys it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
Super excited about being
back on the podcast.
Really, really just hopeful
everybody's doing super well
and let's just really get right into
this conversation with Sam.
I'm gonna let him introduce himself
and then I will take it away.
Sam, why don't you tell the
VaynerNation who you are,
what you're about, and
then we'll go into it.
- Yeah, I'm Sam Parr,
I own this company called The Hustle.
So we started out with
conferences and things like that
and I could talk about that.
But yeah, we had this
conference called Hustle Con
after I sold one company,
I started this thing called Hustle Con.
It's basically like a TED
Talk for entrepreneurs,
but I made it popular by
creating an email newsletter.
And then I was like,
this email newsletter thing's awesome.
So kind of parlayed it into The Hustle.
And so now we're at daily email
with about one and a half
million daily readers.
And Bootstrap, the media company.
Each morning we give, like I said,
about a million and a half
people all the business news
and information they need to know.
And then we've parlayed that
into a bunch of other things
like a paid subscription called Trends,
podcasts and a bunch of
other things like that.
- So how about as a kid,
were you entrepreneurial?
- Yeah, so I grew up in Missouri
and then I went to college in Tennessee.
And when I was in Tennessee,
I owned a chain of hot dog stands called
Southern Sam's: Weiner's
as Big as a Baby's Arm.
(laughing)
- How old were you?
- I started when I was like 20.
But before that, I was
selling stuff on Ebay.
But that was my first legal business,
where I got a business
license and paid taxes,
and things like that.
Have you seen that TV show
called "American Pickers"?
- Yes.
- So Mike, the main guy, the skinny guy.
I met him on the street,
'cause I was a big fan.
And I asked him to work at his store,
he was opening up a store where
they sell all the old shit.
And I worked there, and it was great,
but there was always a
line of a thousand people.
And I was like, "I'm gonna
go open up a hot dog stand
"and sell hot dogs to these people."
And that's what happened.
- Because the show was
so famous that people--
- Yeah when I worked there in 2011,
or no, sorry, 2008 or nine
or something like that,
we were number two on
cable, behind "Pawn Stars."
And all these people from around the world
would come and get in this line.
- Where was that?
- It was in Nashville.
He's into old stuff, right?
So he got this old building
that was away from everything
and there's no restaurants.
And I was like, "Huh."
I from the south so I can say this,
but they're kind of
rednecks who would come
and wait in line and I was like,
these fuckers want some
hot dogs and water,
that's all they want.
And I opened up this hotdog stand
and that was like my first--
- Hustle, official.
- Yeah, first business
that made money and I paid
taxes and got licenses.
- And how did that go?
How long did you do it?
- For a few years,
I mean you would make a
grand a day on a good day.
Yeah, it was awesome
and then I started a website
that made a little bit of money
but I was like oh the
Internet's the way to go
and so I left school and moved up
to Silicon Valley in San Francisco
and originally had job offers at Airbnb
but at the time was called
Air Bed and Breakfast
but I was like you know screw this,
let's try to start something.
So I started a roommate matching
app that had a small exit
and then kind of parlayed
that into The Hustle
and what I'm doing now.
- And what was that company called
and who'd it sell to?
- It was called Bunk originally, Bunk SF.
So what we would do is,
it was kind of funny,
we would cold email all these
landlords and apartments
who had two three, four,
five bedroom apartments
and then we would host parties
so people who had similar wants and needs
for living situations
could all meet one another
and we would help them
move into these buildings
and we would take a small
cut of like a placement fee
and so it was a small exit
like hundreds of thousands of dollars
to Apartment Lists, apartmentlists.com.
- And did you have to work
in that company or no?
- Yeah and I quit on the--
- The first day you could.
- 366 or whatever it was.
Yeah, like that last day.
- How was that, as somebody who now
it sounds like your whole
career has been for yourself
how was that year working somewhere else?
- It was good.
Like I still don't know shit
like I had to read books
on how to run a meeting
so I felt like I moved to
San Francisco from Tennessee
and Griffin, Missouri.
I always felt really uncomfortable
and out of place there
but I love it now.
I didn't know anything,
like I would say things
that were inappropriate,
I would wear stuff I
wasn't supposed to wear.
I just felt horrible so it was good to see
like what an actual businesses run like
but I was also young, I
was 22 and I was partying
and I didn't take it as
seriously as I should have
and I regret that big time,
but it was great to see.
- What would you argue
the one or two or three
biggest takeaways were from that year,
even though you were partying?
- Just like leveling up.
Okay, so you guys have
a great set up here.
You started in like a
small room I imagine,
like a shitty office.
- [Gary] Yes, that's right.
- And so just seeing like wait,
I could take all these little silly things
like a hotdog stand or whatever
and like properly build
it out with nice offices
after you get revenue and like,
in order to get huge as
big as my ambitions were,
you really need to
properly approach things
and be able to like go up
proper levels as opposed to--
- Have you started the challenge proper?
So like for example, what was
funny running through my mind
when you just said you know I read books
on how to run a meeting properly.
I was like laughing in my head
because I was like fuck man,
I probably hate that book.
Because like to me like
meetings and like how the world,
those proper things you're referring to,
seeing meetings and how I
personally see meetings,
there's a huge delta
and how old are you now?
- I'm 30.
- I'm curious,
someone who also came from out of bounds
and never understood
proper, I always wonder,
I'm always challenging myself of like
what was I naturally gifted in,
in an entrepreneurial and human way,
what has evolved over
these 22 years of operating
and what have I taken on that is horseshit
because it's osmosis of the right way.
- Yeah, no, I feel you but
in my mind it's like this.
Okay, when you play an instrument,
when you learn the guitar,
most people don't play
their own songs right away,
they kind of copy other
people and feel the texture
and they go oh, I see some kind of,
like the stuff that I like
I see recurring patterns.
This is interesting, I can
disregard this other stuff
so what I do is I'll usually read books.
- [Gary] I get it.
- I'll read your guys' Glassdoors,
other companies Glassdoors.
I'll be like all right,
what do people say,
what's the baseline for
like what is interesting
and you can cherry-pick.
'Cause you don't know like anything,
it's easier to have like a model
and then you can know what to disregard.
- Yeah, but I would
argue that your analogy
for the way you went about it,
unless I'm missing something
is actually, not flawed,
but not exactly the same analogy
because it sounds like based
on your hot dog business
what you're telling me is
you didn't play other people's music,
you picked it up, started
playing something,
and within that micro area it worked.
I would also argue that
it's really interesting
where the source of
information comes from, right?
So there's a lot of
business books being written
by people who've never run a business.
- Well I usually read biographies.
- Fair enough.
Glassdoor is just anonymous reviews,
and always very dirty data.
- Yeah, so it goes one
far or one other end.
- That's what I mean,
I mean you're at this young age
where you've had these
levels of successes.
I have such empathy for
where you're coming from
because I'm sure I had a
lot of those same feelings
of like I'm from out of bounds,
I don't go to business school
and things of that nature
and I remember ironically
it's interesting for you to bring that up.
I also remember kind of hitting
the Silicon Valley scene
and like every single person
went to Stanford and Harvard.
- [Sam] Yeah, it's uncomfortable.
- And I was like thank God for me,
very different from you,
that I already had such
a real significant win
that I was able to kind of use that
but I have so much empathy
for what must have been
going through your mind
in that scenario.
On the flip side you're catching me
at a very funny time where I would,
what are we, February 24th.
These eight weeks are probably
my favorite eight weeks of
being an operator in a long time
because I decided going into this year
that I was gonna go more me
because I've really let
the company do its thing.
I'm running the company
but I've let the osmosis
of like classic executives
have a lot of say over
the last half decade
and I would argue that
the last eight weeks
have been some of the
most productive weeks
at VaynerMedia's history
and definitely my favorite
time in the last four years
because I'm going back a little bit
to hot dog with the baby arm shit.
- Yeah I don't disagree, we agree.
But it's still important,
it was important for me to understand.
- Right, because you needed that context.
I get it, I get it.
- So like for us, my hotdog thing,
I'd be like all right I'm just gonna take
this thousand dollars of cash,
I'm gonna put that shit
right in my pocket, right?
I'm gonna incriminate myself
but you know what I mean.
- You're gonna spend it on some dumb shit.
- Well I didn't spend, no, no, no.
- Oh, got it, keep going.
- I just didn't do things the right,
didn't do proper accounting,
things like that.
- I get it.
- Now that we have
an eight-figure, we make
seven figures a month,
I think it could be a very large company.
Just learning how to do shit properly.
Not everything needs to be proper.
- [Gary] No, no.
- To the outside world
but like there are some
things where like all right
I got to make sure I do
things the right way.
- [Gary] 100%.
- When things go from
just fucking around--
- Have you brought in
people, like is that how--
- Yeah, Adam is our president,
which I knew from high school.
He's the president, runs a
lot of the day-to-day stuff.
- He's a straight man.
- Yeah, yeah and so I'm able
to kind of be my wild self
and well we don't always
meet in the middle,
sometimes I will still go the wild route
but I have some proper procedures.
Dude, for a while I was
doing the accounting.
- [Gary] Not good.
- I thought cash flow and
revenue were the same thing.
I be like guys we got to get these people
put that money in our
bank, that's not revenue.
I'm not paying your quota on that.
- [Gary] I get it.
- And you learn all that right stuff,
the right way to do it,
that's what I'm referring to.
- I totally understand.
- You know how it is, like
not coming from this area
it's really uncomfortable at first,
but it's actually a
advantage in the end I think.
- [Gary] 100,000%.
- I used to have this book
club called the Anti MBA,
because when I moved to San Francisco
I was so jealous of all
these Stanford people
so I would create this book club
and we'd meet once a week
and then we'd get experts to
come in and lead the discussion
and I was like look, we just
did the same thing as Stanford.
- [Gary] Of course.
- But yeah it's really
uncomfortable I think.
You know how it is.
- What are you thinking
about going forward?
Like where's your mindset
on like the next half
decade, decade, next year,
like as an operator, as a
founder, as an entrepreneur
what's exciting you right now?
- Our business is doing well.
I mean I don't necessarily
care about money
but I'm a runner, I ran in college
and so I love having goals.
I want to hit 100 million
in revenue by 2025
and I'm really excited.
I think there's a lot of
media brands out there
who operate horribly and
aren't doing the right things.
I think we can build a massive
B2B publishing business.
- Explain to me on that,
like what are your hot takes on the--
- I think the New York
media scene is horrible.
- [Gary] Because?
- I think that they look
at Google Analytics more
than actually talk to
users and talk to customers
and figure out like what people want
and they create shit they love.
They don't treat them like customers,
it's just Google Analytics.
It's like oh, we just
change this headline to this
that's gonna do, it's like
what does that really mean
and what you're seeing now is
that's actually impacting
people in the long run.
This is why Bar Stool Sports sold for,
their stock just went up by 50%.
Their sale price was effectively now
like 650 million dollars, right?
And Dave doesn't know shit I
bet at first about analytics.
- [Gary] No, he's an entrepreneur.
- He just made stuff that people loved,
whereas a lot of the big companies,
what are now big, they
don't do that as much
and I think that that's
a huge weakness for them
and will help us.
- So non consumer centric, quant centric.
- Yeah.
- Math.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Which you can have a little bit of that.
- [Gary] Agree.
- Vice, what are they valued at?
Like two or three billion dollars.
- Yeah I mean, I think
when you talk about Vice
you have to talk about the narrative.
I mean one of the variables
in this whole game is,
I don't know the story
so I can't speak to it,
but my perception from the outside is
some of the founders and investors in Vice
did extremely well because--
- Yeah, I saw Shane
Smith sitting front row
at that Tyson Fury fight.
- Yeah I mean, that's a very big part of
VC-backed businesses over
the last half decade,
that will be the legacy
of this 10-year window,
which is what was the
delta between building
long-term businesses,
how much leverage did founders have
to be able to take money off the table
at Series B and Series C levels,
was that what they were
actually going for.
Shane had an again, just
not knowing a lot about Vice
but one thing I definitely knew
because I was in the
circles of medium brands,
Shane had a remarkable ability to sell--
- So good.
- Big brands,
big budgets, so you know
there's so many, I'm with you--
- So here's the difference is,
let's say Vice posts something
like on their social channel
that says our top reporter is
gonna be here tomorrow, show up.
Now let's say Gary posts
I'm gonna be here tomorrow,
show up, who's gonna have the most pull.
- [Gary] Of course.
- Right, yet they have a billion dollars
or 800 million dollars in
funding or something like that.
- [Gary] Yep.
- That's to me is my point.
- Are you self-funded for this business?
- We took a little bit of angel money
so I had self-funded it.
The first couple conferences
I made 500 grand in profit
and I piled all that money into this,
then we took small
checks from Tim Ferriss,
the founders of Nerd Wallet,
the founders of Bleach Report.
People like that.
- People that you thought
could bring value.
- Yeah because I was like
emailing these people
and I would ask them questions
and they're like can I invest?
I'm like wait, you're gonna give me money
and I can just text you
questions whenever I want?
So we did a little bit of
that but no venture capital.
- What's the best piece
of advice you've gotten
from either smart money or outside people
or you consumed somewhere in the last,
let's call the last year?
- Just some personal advice,
Joe Speiser who started LittleThings.com,
which eventually went out,
but he's very successful.
He was like I'm gonna write you this check
but just know I just bought
a big house in the Hamptons,
it's not gonna make you happy.
And so like he gave me that
right when he gave us the money.
What are some other good advice?
Tim Ferriss has been really helpful.
I mean he's like anal
retentive about his brand
and about everything like that.
- [Gary] He is, he's super thoughtful.
- I think there's a
little middle ground there
but like just seeing like how
strict he is with his brand
and it totally works for him
and it has made him so much money.
- It's authentically him.
- It's so good and I really respect that.
- Where are you at this point in your life
between money, legacy, the process?
If I said 30-year old
you right now between,
generally in your stomach,
in your heart, in your gut,
about how much you're driven
by and how much you like
the net win is around dollars
is around being able to do your process
and around legacy, how are
you currently broken down
between 100% on those three?
- Well I don't have children yet
so maybe things will change
but I have enough that
I don't have to worry for maybe forever.
I thought I was really money motivated
but when you get all these opportunities
when you get to a little bit of a level
like we'll pay you 10 grand
to come here and do this
or whatever and I found
myself not wanting to do that
because I'm like ugh, that
sounds so boring to me,
I don't want to do that.
So I guess that answers the question
of where I am a little bit.
I mean like one time we
had a client do something
that we thought was an asshole
thing and we fired them
and we lost a quarter of a million dollars
and I slept like a baby.
So I don't think I'm as
money motivated as I thought.
- Do you think that's because
you checked some sort of box
for yourself along the way
versus 20 year old you?
- No, here's what I say.
I had fuck you money when I had 10 grand.
- [Gary] Yeah I get that.
- You know what I'm saying?
- [Gary] Yeah, I do know that.
- And then once I was like wait a minute--
- I still don't think
I've ever been more rich
than when I was doing
baseball card shows at 13
because $3000, $4000 when you're 13
and you came from nothing,
I thought I had like a trillion.
- I remember one day I sold hotdogs
and I had a grip of cash,
it was like a grand.
- A grip.
It was just a grip.
- I called it a grip, let me get that grip
and it was because I had
like a jar here for tips
and I had like a grand in five
dollar bills and I was like
this is fucking money.
- I made it.
- This is it.
I was like we called it hood rich and--
- Where did you grow up again?
- In St. Louis Missouri
but then I lived in Nashville, Tennessee
but I grew up with a
lot of like poor people
and you know that's why I talk like this.
- Did you like it, did you think about--
- I was you happy.
So in Nashville I lived across
the street from the projects
and we would hang out all the time--
- And how old were you then?
- 19 to 21, 18 to 21.
And I would just hang out
there with my buddy Rydell
and we would just chill and just sit on,
that was my happiest when I had nothing,
which is weird, right?
- No, I think it's not weird at all.
And what'd you guys talk about?
Just like guy talk, girls,
sports, just random shit
or would you talk about dreams?
- Business, yeah.
I mean he, this dude had
served 25 years in prison
and we would talk about that
but just stupid stuff.
But it's really fun.
I think that when you come from not a lot,
which you know I had a
good family and everything
but when you're trying to start
on your own from scratch--
- And do you have siblings?
- Yeah, yeah.
I have siblings, older
brother and older sister.
- [Gary] You were the youngest.
- Mm-hmm yeah.
I think when you start from not a lot,
it's actually a huge advantage
and you could be a lot happier that way.
I think if you're born
into a wealthy family
the likelihood of like depression
might actually be higher.
- [Gary] I think so.
- [Sam] You know what I mean?
- Based on our societal norms right now.
So much of my passion about
like what I talk about
and the content I put out
is to create empathy for,
it's very hard you know,
I get it, I grew up in it.
it's very hard for somebody
that doesn't have much
to have empathy for
somebody who's driving a BMW
and has a Rolex but you know,
based on all my readings,
all my DMs I get,
at this point in my life I
have hundreds of thousands
of interactions per month,
year, whatever it is.
It's just a lot of interactions.
I see far more sadness in
people that had too much
than in people had too little.
I see envy in people
that don't have as much.
I see drive in people
I see resentment in people
that don't have as much.
I see deep lostness in
people that had too much.
You know?
When people didn't have as much
there is an inherent I'm
gonna pull myself out of this
whether it's illegal,
legal, there's a drive.
It's really hard to be
hungry when you started fed.
It just is.
- No and I agree.
- And I have I have wealthy kids
and I think about it constantly.
- So let me ask you a question that
I bet a lot of people
wonder or maybe a fair bit,
so you started this from nothing.
- [Gary] Yep.
- I started my business from nothing.
I saw early on, even once we
got to like 25, 30 employees
once it got to like 10
million in revenue I was like,
I don't want to operate
or I don't want to like be
the guy of this business.
I want to just go start
from the bottom again
and start stuff within the company.
That's what I prefer.
You seem like you would prefer that
but it seems like you're
still like the guy in charge.
- I do both.
The reason I have team Gary is
it is my little pirate ship.
- How many people work there?
- [Gary] Team Gary?
- Yeah.
- 30 or so, right, feels right?
So I have GaryVee, my team Gary,
my K-Swiss collaboration,
my Empathy Wine--
- Is that a separate entity?
- K-Swiss?
- No, your team Gary.
- No, it is part of VaynerMedia.
- So how do you allocate budget to that?
- We allocate it because
I have full control
and we look at it as two things.
One, the testing ground for hypotheses
that become the scalable
strategies and talent grooming
and top of the funnel business awareness.
We don't have to do RFPs
'cause I'm Gary Vee.
Gary Vee happened because of Team Gary
so it instead of most
companies that I compete with
at the level that we compete at
who have enormous allocations
to new business teams
and spend tons of money on RFPs,
we do none of that and it amortizes out
into the content engine,
which becomes far more strategic
than spending $50,000 on a sizzle reel
to try to get McDonald's to hire you.
I just walk in and say, "Hire us dick."
- Do you like running
an 800 person company?
- Yes.
You know one thing with
me that is interesting
and I would argue that it
is potentially a weakness
because I have so much magic,
back to kind of where
you're going with this,
ironically I also had a ton
of operational capability.
I've basically been the COO,
the operating decision maker
for my companies my whole life.
I mean AJ played that role
but he was by nature having
an 11-year younger brother,
he was so capable so it was great
but there was a lot of
operational conversations
we had together and so
I am capable to operate
and I often debate with myself, fuck,
even though I love it, I love it.
Ultimately I operate because
I actually like operating
because I have a real
interesting distinction
between the sizzle and the steak
that both sit within me, that is me.
- Who's your number two or
number three, number four?
- So at Vayner really,
at VaynerMedia my number two is really,
I mean it's really an interesting mix.
- [Sam] Like a CFO?
- Yes and no, right?
Because I'm not CFO driven
and listening to your stories
I get where you're coming from.
And I have a lot of that too,
like I'm far better at
literally doing something
nobody else can do than
balancing checkbooks,
like it's just boring as fuck to me,
back to cash flow and EBITDA.
I went through all those same things,
I'm like fuck this.
But what I will tell you is
my number two is a collective
I would argue between Claude,
I always think of Claude as my number two
because she's the chief heart officer,
which is really HR which I
really believe is the punch line.
- She creates like the hiring roadmap?
- Yeah but she's also gray.
She even has a number two in Generosa,
like she herself is kind
of like more you and me
then she is a straight person
but I think that's exactly right for HR.
HR is a function of humanity,
same way you cynically,
properly by the way,
cynically look at all the
Google Analytics media companies
that's how I think about HR.
I don't give a fuck about
fucking hiring structure.
I care about humanity.
I don't care about fucking all the stuff
we're supposed to do for
the states that were in
though we have to do
that so we don't get sued
and become liable but what I care about is
Claude knowing what fucking is on,
I sat down with Seth.
I'm looking right at him right now.
I had something cancel.
I see Seth on the fucking floor
and I literally was like
Seth, come into my office
and we have a 10 minute
talk about Seth's life.
This is real life.
This happened a week ago, right Seth?
Like that's what I'm about.
And I don't want to speak for Seth,
it's probably hard for me to ask you
being in the room but
I have a funny feeling
Seth's relationship with
VaynerMedia is better today
than it was a week and a half ago
because we got to have that
talk, clarity and roadmap.
That's how you build a big,
your game is not gonna
be like at real scale,
when I hear the level of
ambition of 100 million by 2025.
One, I personally get scared about that.
First of all, you know yourself.
I'm not a runner thus it makes sense to me
but I'm always inherently always nervous
because I'm like don't put
that extra pressure on you.
But to your point you know
how to motivate yourself,
you do you.
Number two, my belief is
no matter how remarkable
the two of you are on kind of
like the sizzle and the steak
that the most important variable
to get to a hundo is HR.
- Okay, so you have your
HR person report to you?
- [Gary] Which both of you
might be remarkable at,
I just don't know.
- He's very good at it.
- I believe you.
- I'm good at recruiting.
- Understood, makes sense.
Hunting farming.
- Yeah so you have Claude.
- Claude then Marc Yudkin
our general counsel
far out seeds that title.
He's far more of a COO.
He's been here from basically day one.
He was my personal lawyer
when I invested in Twitter
and Facebook and he's like
this kid must be right
and I recruited him and
we had a general counsel
long before I thought it was appropriate
but I just knew he was right
and I was like fuck it,
I'll get there eventually.
And good because he's been a concierge
or whatever the fuck you call those things
and a general counsel and is evolving more
and more into COO life.
Marcus Krzastek who's
my brother's best friend
since first grade started here
should have never worked at Vayner
but the economy collapsed
and he was a super bright kid
and I had like nothing but finance offers
but like he's an EQ kid it turns out
and was smart enough to come here
and just intern and
he's my chief of staff.
He's a quote-unquote number two.
I would argue that and an
Allen would agree with me.
Allen probably falls more
into a number three as a CFO.
I'm just basically I'm on
the hyperbole, not hyperbole,
I'm in the real life of
pay the bills, invest,
pay the bills, invest.
It's all in perpetuity so
I'm not looking to extract
too many dollars out of the business
at this point in my life
because I can afford to
and so I want to build a machine.
My admin team Alex, Lou, Max.
My admin team is a real factor in my life.
Back to the joke we made before here,
like for everybody who's listening,
I sat down and was like all right.
Exited be on your podcast.
He looked at me he's like,
"Motherfucker, I'm on yours."
I'm like, "Oh shit."
That's how I am.
- We'll publish on our
channel if you want us too.
- I'm sure you will,
but I don't need you to.
But it was a great insight for you of like
how high level I'm really playing it
'cause it really
ultimately doesn't matter.
Like the context I needed for here
as you can see in the way,
I mean I know enough, I
know enough from afar,
I know enough of like right,
I know how to bring the most
value to you and to my audience
so like I don't spend time on things
that I don't need to spend time on.
- So we have this thing we launch Trends,
it's pretty cool where we do,
we basically uncover
interesting opportunities.
- Makes a ton of sense.
- Yeah, so it's basically like--
- I've seen the model my whole life.
- It's a paid newsletter
with a group and community
and we're gonna scale up
like POLITICO Pro, whatever.
And the point with Trends right now is
we're uncovering cool opportunities
so we'll do like a case
study on a cool company
like right now I'm writing one
just on the hotel industry.
I think there's a lot of
opportunities in hotels
and we'll kind of
breakdown the financials.
- [Gary] I love that.
- Or we have technology crawls the web
to find things that are
fast-growing like for example,
people are searching
for ways to sleep better
more than they're searching
for meditation stuff.
- [Gary] I'm aware.
- And so we just will uncover that
and talk about what it means.
- It's cool.
- Just exploring that opportunity
and one of the things that
we talked about on that
and on our podcast is just like the real,
like the economics of different things,
of different businesses
and how they operate.
How many employees do you guys have?
- We have almost 900.
- Okay shit, so what I'm curious about
and I think a lot of people might be is
so I made about $400,000,
$500,000 in profits
from the conference,
that's what I used to fund
our advertising business.
Now those made a lot of profits,
which fund this thing and that thing
and so that's our funding route.
How were you guys able
to scale to 800 people?
Did you get a line of credit?
- No, we got a free conference
room the size of this.
So that was our first overhead.
Me and AJ didn't take any salary.
AJ saved money from eBay
in high school in college.
I was an interesting spot.
I didn't own Wine Library.
The part of my narrative a
lot of people don't realize is
in family businesses like
almost every employee made
as much if not more than me.
So in my 20s I was making 42, 57, 63,
so the last couple years I got up to
a little around a hundred
but I lived in New York
and right before Vayner started
I took all my liquid and invested in
Facebook, Twitter, and Tumblr.
- Can you reveal how much?
- How much did I put in?
Like 220, 47, and 71.
So somewhere in the ballpark of
in my whole life I've been able to save
about 400 thousand bucks
because I paid like eight, $900 in rent
and I worked 18 hours a day.
- And you put all 400 to those--
- [Gary] All of it.
- That's fucking crazy.
- It was crazy but if you
think about how big of a win,
it's kind of like sports cards right now.
So like this sports card
thing is really funny.
- We just covered those
auctions on Trends actually.
- [Gary] I love that.
- Heritage Auctions.
- Yes.
- It's growing like crazy.
- Crazy and like LeBron rookies
have gone up from a thousand
like it's really funny.
I think a lot of people
think I'm talking about
sports cards right now
because I know my narrative
that I grew up with them
but I also try to remind
my closest friends
who are like calling
me now and be like yo,
especially as they see the
videos of like me and April
saying buy LeBron at a
thousand, now it's 4500.
Buy Gianna's for 180, now it's 1500.
Buy Luca for 35, now it's 280.
Like now I've got like the receipts
and it's happened within six months
and everyone's like wait a minute
is there something actually happening here
and I told my friends, I'm like look,
I've been passionate about
sports cards since I was 11.
I also haven't said a word
about them for 20 years.
So it's really happening.
The reason I bring that up is
this is one of the first things I've seen
that is so unbelievably obvious to me
that I did the same thing
that I did with investing,
which is if it's 100%, not 99.
If it's 99, I'm an immigrant
and I'm gonna hold 50% back,
but if it's 100 and
YouTube, excuse me Facebook,
Twitter and Tumblr were a 100% to me
and that was right.
- So that crushed it.
- We sold an $8400 campaign to a guy
that I went to a basketball game with
who was a Wine Library
customer who invited me
because he was a huge collector
and literally in the second quarter
of this boring Nets game in
the old stadium in Jersey,
he goes, "So what are you up to?"
I was like actually 'cause I felt calm,
I hadn't told anybody.
I was like actually my
brother's about to graduate
in two months and I'm gonna
start a business with him
and I'm probably gonna spend,
you know what I said.
I know what I said to him,
I'm like I'm gonna be 150%.
Don't worry, I'm gonna
be a 100% on Wine Library
because he's my big customer
but I'm gonna put a lot
of effort into building
this company with my brother
and turns out that he was in marketing
and he had this big campaign for Gillette
starting around when before AJ graduated.
Our first campaign was
before AJ graduated,
it was like this bullshit
influencer Twitter campaign
in Vegas for Gillette's razors
and they paid us $84,000,
which I thought was like a trillion,
especially compared to what we did.
I tried to get them to
do like 94 smart things,
they're like no, just
take some photos here.
I'm like all right.
Nonetheless that 84000 is the funding.
- That's pretty crazy to me
because with our business
I mean we haven't taken a lot of funding
but I still am like how close
do we want to run our margins
but you have to like put
money up for rent, right?
So in San Francisco and here,
you gotta your deposit in--
- Well it's funny right?
We have a lot of jobs
we're putting out there
at like you know 40 and 50
and people are like how
can you live in New York<
They like yell at me
and I'm like by not living in Manhattan,
by not buying $7 Starbucks,
by not taking Uber instead of the train.
Like you could do anything.
To your point you know you were in
a little bit different place,
you were in that world,
you made a couple hundred,
you made some money on that exit.
You were also in the cocoon of fun,
you were in San Francisco cocoon.
- Yeah, well now most of
our people are in Austin.
- Exactly like you know you
from mentality of St. Louis
and Nashville and you
know you as the person
that was living in a
cocoon of San Francisco.
You can do anything if you're
willing to not be entitled,
if you're willing to be practical.
This is where Americans get caught
with immigrants all the time.
How can this happen?
Very easy, like you live humbly as fuck,
you save money and you
then deploy that money,
it's not super complicated.
You did it, I did it,
my dad definitely did it
and like a billion fucking
people have done it in America
over the last 100 years.
It's that people are
impatient and insecure
and so yeah, I mean that's how we did it.
We didn't pay rent for the first
two and a half years of the company.
- So you guys were running
on a slim bank balance
even for a couple years?
- Yes and no.
We didn't pay rent.
Again, because I bartered,
I asked, like you know?
I already had a little street cred
because of my wine business
so I was able to use me a
little bit, so that's true.
- I just think that when
you have like 300 employees
it's like shit.
- Like yeah but by that
point we had, 300 employees
we were doing 87 million
dollars in revenue.
Like you know at that
point you're balancing it.
But yeah I mean,
you know what it comes down to
and I'm curious how you think about this
and I hope you've been
able to hold on to this
because they'll make you unstoppable.
I'm actually secretly
excited about a headline
in the New York Times that says,
VaynerMedia lays off half of
his staff after the recession
because if I made the wrong decisions,
which won't happen but if I did,
I'd still be okay with it.
Here's why, I deserve it.
I made the mistake.
I liked being accountable.
I'm really into accountability.
I really think it needs
to get like super cool.
Alex, do me a favor text Andy K right now
and tell him I want it,
accountable as fuck,
hoodie made immediately.
I want to wear it.
See if we can get it to me this afternoon.
Accountable as fuck.
In the same way, I apologize,
I just want to say this.
Like in the same way that I
think kindness and empathy
and patience needed to be a bigger part
of the formula of entrepreneurship,
which is why I've talked
about it a lot more.
I think accountability.
I just wish that every entrepreneur
back to your point, razor thin margins.
What does that mean?
You can get caught.
If you're okay with getting caught
and paying the ramifications, you win.
If you're not as you know
and I've been listening
to you on this interview
people creating exits in media land,
creating exits that
look like it's an exit,
you know it wasn't an exit,
they sold their assets
for a penny on the dollar
but they didn't have the
guts to say we shut down
so they sold early, right?
People are not willing
to be uncomfortable.
I'm willing to put my own
cash back into VaynerMedia
if I fucked up.
I'm willing to have to let
go 10% of worst employees
at Vayner if nine of our clients fire us.
Like shit changes, things happen.
- Well I do these exercises
and I tell Adam about it all the time.
I just do these exercises all the time
where I'm like if this business
goes out of business
tomorrow, I'll be fine.
- You know why?
'Cause you will be fine.
- Right and so that's all right
and I do that exercise
all the time because--
- It's so good, love that.
- I remember when we first started,
I was like man if this, my
personality so tied up in this,
now it's like if we go away tomorrow,
I'll be just as happy.
When you protect your downside,
you have no downside then
and it's only upside.
And so that's kind of how we discuss it.
- I've said it a billion
times I'll say it again.
I want to lose everything,
have everybody shit on me,
say that I was a farce the whole time,
see how everybody else was better than me,
I was the joke.
Make fun of all the people
that bought into me,
all that and then just rise back up
and fucking tell everybody
go fuck themselves.
Like I'm into that shit.
- Yeah, I mean it's really helpful.
It's freeing.
- It's unbelievably freeing.
- [Sam] It's very freeing.
- What else is exciting
for you to talk about?
What else is on your mind?
What else do you think will
bring value to people listening?
What's been, actually
let me ask you this way.
What's been something that
you feel your readers,
which I'm sure overlap very
heavily with this audience,
I'm sure plenty of them read already,
have been really hot on?
What do you guys put out
and you're like fuck,
we knew it and yeah, they
really are hot on it?
- Well I want to talk
specific business things
that we're going over
so like different ideas
and concepts and I mean I'm really bullish
on a bunch of things, but first one thing
that we speak a lot about is focus.
And this is a little fluffy
so we don't spend too much I'm on it
but when you get to a certain point
you have the ability to do
a lot of different things.
So I have invested in a ton of shit.
But now I'm like oh fuck,
I gotta pay attention to
that real estate deal,
can't pay attention to this,
I really need to focus on only this thing
and maybe one other thing.
What's your criteria for
saying no and saying yes?
- Complete intuition every time
and when I say yes to things
outside the core Vayner X
I always treat it as it goes to zero
but I know that I need it
because I need to get my
entrepreneurial nut off.
- So what's that mean then?
- That means that I need to absolutely
make that $50,000
investment or do that thing
to make the whole machine work
AKA the 25% of things I'm
doing that make no sense
and stretch me too thin
are actually the thing
that gives me sanity and happiness,
which allows us 75% of the Vayner focus
to actually run at 150%.
- So Empathy Wines is one of them?
- Yes.
- And so that's your 25%?
- It's one of them.
I mean look, you know I'm a funny guy.
I talk a lot about a lot of things
and I don't talk about some
of the best things about me
like who I am as a human in like the deep,
like what Alex knows,
not what you guys know.
My nonprofits and my board work there,
I don't talk about that.
I also don't talk about
my single biggest exit.
I co-founded and co-created
Resy, the restaurant app,
like literally me and Ben
Leventhal over dinner.
He came up with the idea,
they were incubated at VaynerMedia
when the company was in a bad moment.
I personally put money in,
I spent a lot of social
capital getting Danny Meyer
and Steve Ross deeply involved.
Ben and Mike Montero or
absolutely the drivers
of that business but like I
am easily the birth father
and the third player in that story.
It's a hefty nine figure exit to Amex
and I have a funny feeling
that 93% of the people
that just heard a story
heard it for the first time.
Case was sold nine months ago.
There is no confusion to why.
I barely mentioned it.
I have just tweeted about it this week
and everyone's like all oh, congrats.
So I need those things to make me sane,
they've also led to a ton of big wins.
The Resy win covers every
potential loss I have.
- Yeah, that's sold to Airbnb?
- It's sold to, no, Airbnb
was an investor though.
it's sold to Amex, American Express.
- [Sam] And it was good?
- It was extremely good.
Hefty nine figures.
- No shit.
- Wow, congratulations.
- So I think that I
have to do a better job
of like communicating
some of those things too--
- Did you guys raise money for that?
- We did, we did.
First from Vayner RSE,
my fund incubated it.
- So you got a double win then?
- I got a double win.
I got a triple win because
I put personal money in
when it needed it.
But the reality is, is that
I think when I hear you say that
I have a lot of empathy for you
because I have a funny feeling
we cross over in a lot of ways.
I would tell you that
don't over look at it
from a black-and-white standpoint
'cause to your point,
I mean there's so many things.
When you come from nothing,
like when people email me
and say Gary, bad news,
really sorry but the investment you wrote
into my company's going to zero,
we're shutting down the doors,
but don't worry I learned a lot.
I get pissed, I'm like
fuck you motherfucker.
Like $50,000, $100,000
is a ton of money to me.
Like it doesn't matter how much I make,
I earned that, I bled for that,
I bled for that shit.
But I also would say
to you on the flip side
I'm sure what you're realizing is
some of those checks you wrote,
when you wrote it you imagined
how much you were gonna
help that thing to success
and now you may never
talk to that founder.
And I think that happened to me
and the way I look at it now,
A, I changed my behavior a little bit.
B--
- [Sam] What do you mean?
- I stopped investing as much
and would invest where I
thought by accident I could help
just by maybe, you know
when you build a brand too
your name can help.
I have absolutely invested
when I believed in something
and believed in the person
and knew that my investment
would help them raise more money.
So I've thought a lot about that.
But yeah, I think all
those micro losses is
why I'm gonna macro win.
I need it, I'm an artist.
I'm creative by nature, I need it.
- So you wanna talk about
some interesting things
that we've been going over
in The Hustling on Trends
that I think you'll enjoy ripping on.
- [Gary] Please.
- Okay so you guys,
Vayner had a real estate
conference, right?
- [Gary] Yes.
- How'd that go, financially?
- Financially it went well.
Where it was vulnerable was--
- I heard you said something stupid too.
You got in trouble.
- No, I didn't get to say anything stupid.
I still believe in it, I said that--
- Sorry, I don't mean
stupid, I mean backlash.
- You didn't hurt my feelings,
I know what you meant.
Three things.
One, right, so to your point on that,
one, it was Agent 2021, it
was run 100% by Kim Garcia.
I always knew that Kim
might not stay long-term
and so there was the vulnerability
was unlike anything else
I do at VaynerMedia.
There was no backup to Kim
going on in her career,
which is why we didn't do it this year.
As far as the backlash,
I'll triple down on it right now--
- Which I agree with you--
- A stunning amount of
people overextend themselves
on their first house purchase
just to say they bought a home.
Everybody almost maximizes
their down payment,
which eliminates cash flow.
Almost everybody buys a
home that's too big for them
and has an extra bedroom or
living room that they never use
and I think for people
that are entrepreneurial
and are trying to grow happiness
and business capabilities
that they need to rethink
their buying home strategy
and lean into more renting
so that they have the
liquid to go on the offense
so they can then buy a
home at 39 or 57 or never
so I believe in that
and then so the industry took that as,
Gary says never buy home and I love that.
My sister's a real estate agent.
I believe in a triple and when
I tell you I give no fucks
to the backlash of people
that have financial vested interest
in people buying homes for themselves,
not having empathy for the
person that buys the home,
they can go fuck themselves.
- So this next conference of yours
sounds like it's gonna go great.
(laughing)
- Yeah, I mean the
conference is easy, right?
Like the conference like is--
- But that was a good
business for you guys?
- It was an okay business.
We made six figures on both executions
through sponsorships and ticket sales.
I love the events business.
- Yeah, so let's talk about it.
So I did a big case study,
I studied the top five companies.
You know there's a company called Informa,
you know Informa?
- I do.
- I love Informa, it's a 15
billion dollar market cap.
Their margins are significantly larger
than a lot of these huge tech companies,
like Atlassian, things like
that who I compared them to.
I mean they could do three or
four billion dollars a year
in tradeshow revenue with like
a 40% net income margin, fat.
And there's some lacking
in the construction field
and a few other industries
but I love the trade
show industry, I love it.
I think there's a huge opportunity there.
And what were you saying
about why you love 'em?
- Because they're highly profitable
and humans will continue to interact
and everyone's attention is
unscalable tech, not humanity
and non-scalable shit like that
and at scale you can really do damage.
- Yeah but a lot of
people don't realize it
because it seems kind of
unsexy, it's not interesting.
- I mean bro every single one
of my friends made fun of me
for starting VaynerMedia.
It's a client service business.
And to your point back to like
why I would never judge somebody
that wants to do a hundo in 2025,
you know how you navigate
by being a runner
that gives me a lot of insight.
Actually gives me a lot of insight of me.
I never compete with myself.
I don't run or whatever,
though I was pumped I did
break my jump rope record
this Sunday with Mike on how
many I can do in 12 minutes,
but nonetheless, I would tell you that
non-sexy businesses right now
that have true business
fundamentals are by far
the most interesting thing.
- What else is more interesting then?
- Sports cards, I'm sorry
to bring it up again.
All my friends are like this is stupid,
it's all gonna go tech.
I'm like cool, I really don't think so.
Like physical things are not
going away from our society.
- So then where the opportunities,
through exchange marketplaces?
- Yeah somebody's gonna build a true,
you know there's something called CalmSea.
There's a company running around right now
raising capital that's a true
merkel exchange type thing
where you never take any of the cards,
you short, you buy futures.
Yes, I also think sports like music
is a fundamental pillar.
I love history.
The Romans biggest events
where people fucking fighting
each other, like boxing
and fighting a lion
and whatever the fuck but
like this is never going away
and I think that if you look at culture,
look at all of us right now.
There's a lot of young
professionals in this room.
I'm gonna call myself young.
The way we're dressed,
like every person here
doing the same thing we're
doing right now in 1974
looks totally different.
The casual nature, the culture nature,
and I think art is not this
generations favorite thing
though there's cool art and
there's a lot of fun things
and I'm actually in an
art business I like a lot
called IKONICK, but--
- Yeah, the posters.
- Uh-huh, I'm a very big fan
that because of sneaker culture
and because of urban culture
that I think that sports cards
are about to become the next art
and so like a lot of what I'm buying
whether it's Colin
Kaepernick, which is cultural,
not what he can do on the field
because he's probably not
gonna be on the field again
or basketball, soccer, wrestling cards.
I think they're the next art.
- What's another way
you'd attack that market?
- Shovels and picks, right?
'Cause I'm just, you know back to the way
you asked that question.
The more thoughtful business,
the one that I've less interest in
but where the bigger economics are
is the infrastructure around it.
Let's just parlay our two conversations.
The core event is called The National.
It's the biggest sports card show.
- How big is it?
- I don't know.
- [Sam] Do you know who owns it?
- I do not but I can tell you
since I've been to the last two
it's great and it's part
of the hobbies tradition
but there's clearly opportunity
and I don't know on the comp of Comic-con
if the people that originally owned it
then just became what it became today.
I would love that for the
family that's been in it
on the national but either
them or a competitor coming in
clearly has an opportunity
to create an events business
that is going to matter
because you can see the,
like regional shows are so mom and pop.
I mean it's exactly what
you think they look like
but there's a place for
it to go pop culture.
There's grading companies,
the whole industry is built on--
- That's badass.
I would do that route.
- PSA is a publicly traded company
that I think the stock
has done well recently.
They're starting the IP company,
they're starting the next brand,
Upper Deck, Topps, Fleer.
- PSA?
- PSA is the grading company,
there's three leaders in grading.
SGC, PSA--
- Is this like a Moody's?
- What's a Moody's?
- For stocks.
- I don't know, what's a Moody's?
- Moody's, what's another?
- The bass line.
- They give you like the A, AAA rating.
The ratings company.
- Yeah, this is a little bit more flawed,
it's human, it's like
appraisal on how good the card,
there's a lot of anxiety of this business
because there's people
that try to trim cards
or alter cards, authenticity
like it's humans grading.
- That's awesome, I like that business.,
- There's being an IP company,
right now Panini or
Topps own all the rights,
but you could start a new company
or buy one of the old brands
and then get the rights from the MBA
or them or the MLB so there's
the IP renting company
kind of like ESPN and Fox
get the rights for the leagues,
that's how sports cards work.
There's the expansion,
I've been thinking a lot
about creating hip hop cards,
like you know what
would happen if you went
into a new arena and created cards.
Pokemon and Magic the Gathering
haven't even started the process,
they're already ridiculously expensive
but that age group is younger.
That was the 90s generation cards
whereas the 80s was sports.
So there's non sports cards.
There's a lot of variables.
- So I'm gonna have our
analyst and our team go and--
- I love it.
- Write that up.
- Please and I'll give a ton exposure.
I've heard from a lot
of people the quality
of your guys work is really good
so if you're gonna go
really deep and do it,
I know it on surface level intuition
and like little parts but
like some of the data,
like I don't know if there's
been a single better thing
to invest in in the last
year than sports cards
including crypto, anything good
that has happened in
crypto, cannabis, stock
like we're talking about 20, 30, 40X
return in six and nine months, liquid.
Like one thing that you know that sucks
about angel investing is you're locked.
- Yeah, for eight years, 10 years.
- Right, I bought 53 of them.
I wish I bought 500 of them.
You buy 53 LeBrons last spring,
I'm talking eight months
ago for a thousand,
they're fucking 4,500 right now
and there's demand.
- Are there young people
buying it or older?
- Everybody, it's just happening.
I'll tell you who's buying.
My generation that now has wealth
that's going back to
their childhood nostalgia,
always works.
Their eight year olds,
so the kids of the core group.
Gamblers, the amount of
gambling culture in sports
is heavy, daily fantasy,
actual betting, prop betting,
you've seen all that explosion.
Well guess what?
Like if you know sports
another way to gamble
is to put it into players you believe in.
And then sneaker flipper kids.
The enormity of that industry
that has been massively
disrupted by stock X and IPOs,
you can't go to the sneaker store anymore
and hire 80 of your high school friends
to stand in line, get the Yeezys,
bring them back, give them 10 bucks each,
and then go make real money.
- Yeah that's wild, I've
enjoyed watching that thing.
What's another industry that
has been exciting to you?
- DTC brands that are not VC-backed.
Slow and steady, I'm
gonna build a $39 million
T-shirt business, gum
business, honey business,
but I'm not gonna do it like Casper--
- Or Outdoor Voices, you see that?
- Correct, I didn't see yet.
- The CEO had to step down.
I don't know if it's
fired or stepped down.
Okay, how much did they raise?
Do you know?
Like 40 or 50 million dollars.
They raise 50 million
dollars or something,
the revenue was only 49
and they're losing two
million dollars a month.
I've got a friend that has a
business that sells dog ramps
that does three million a
month in revenue with nothing.
I mean it's crazy how--
- Brother, this is the whole theme
of this whole conversation.
It's why I pressed early on.
The more we don't become like it,
the more likely we're
gonna be super all right.
Hot dog you is the best version of you.
- [Sam] Yeah.
- And I think that that is
what we're on the dawn of.
I think a lot of what I'm talking about,
do you understand the utter carnage.
If this coronavirus thing
continues its momentum,
let there be no confusion.
I don't know when we're airing this.
I assume this week, next week,
so it's not gonna be too far
but like as of this morning--
- Spain was, people in Spain,
or Milan are being shut down.
- Again, I'm headline reading
so I'm talking out of my
ass and not out of my ass.
I just had a breakfast,
I look up, all red.
CNBC coronavirus.
I had a friend hit me up over
the weekend saying like hey,
in America this is a little
bit weirder than you think,
this is who my uncle is.
I'm like that's weird.
- Wait, wait, what's that mean?
- Just said hey this is
more serious in America
than you think and you'll be finding out
in next hundred days.
And I'm not a big conspiracy theorist
so putting that out there
I hope I've scared nobody
but like I'm just sharing,
like where I'm going is whether
it's fucking coronavirus
or the inevitable economic downturn,
nobody's building real businesses anymore.
You know that.
All of Silicon Valley
New York to your point,
nobody's building actual businesses.
- Yeah, I think it's crazy
that these people raise money
for some of these D2C brands.
It's crazy.
- It's because they can,
there's so much money in the system.
There's too much money in the system.
- And they don't realize
they'll get way richer
by not doing that.
- They like the perception of success
versus actual success.
- Because it's actually
incredibly cheap to do this.
- The perception, also brother
I'll tell you this though.
It's time we talk about
entrepreneurship and talent.
You and I got lucky in
the fucking DNA game.
It is not so easy.
I understand what you're
saying and I say it too,
let's flip it around.
It's actually super hard to
build a sustainable business
where you're not being
fucking trust funded.
All these startups are trust funds.
- What I always tell people
I'm like intellectually
it's not that hard, emotionally
it's super challenging
and they can't just balance.
- Good news, nothing's
complicated intellectually.
This is all emotion.
People don't have the stomach
for losing and judgment.
- Yeah, I mean starting these D2C brands,
like I know a bunch of people doing it.
I'm like this is really not that hard.
- You'll appreciate this, ready?
What's more fun for 99%
of the people listening
and the world right now?
Hey, go raise money and
look like you're killing it
and have CEO in your Instagram title
and have money to go spend
because you're paying yourself
enough and all this stuff
or eat dog shit for four and a half years
to build a foundation to maybe
get to that same exact place
but you're on stable ground
and then you can start the process
and maybe in eight years it can look good.
The end.
Who the fuck is gonna pick
eight years over eight minutes?
1%, which is why that one
percent's about to win big.
- Is there anything else you like?
I'm fascinated by the
whole psychedelic thing.
- Oh, that's so obvious to me.
Like the whole Aubrey and
Ferriss and all that circles.
- I'm huge on it.
- Men's makeup.
- Men's makeup, what?
- [Gary] Men's makeup.
- Can you write that down?
- I know we're wrapping,
everyone's trying to get us to wrap up
and we're having too much fun.
I got a real hot take, not short term.
Sports cards short term.
- Wait, talk about psychedelics though.
- What I can tell is that psychedelics
are only repressed as a stigma.
- Have you ever done them?
- No.
- I don't drink, I don't do any drugs.
- I never even smoked a cigarette,
like I'm super weird.
- Do you drink?
- Yeah, I drink wine,
but I've been drunk like five times.
- I'm completely sober and I love that
but I still love that thing.
- Yeah me too 'cause I don't have feelings
and opinions when it comes to business.
- Would you do 'em?
- I probably wouldn't because my mom Nancy
Reaganed me out too much.
It's a framework for me,
but I'll say this I'll never say never.
Like I'm willing to do
whatever the fuck I need to do
at any point, it's just
not in my framework.
On the flip side, I'm
also way too grateful
and thankful of my mental happiness
and I would be lying if I didn't tell you
that I'd be scared to alter something
or lot of people do it
because it finds a dimension
that works for them.
I'm like my current
state is working for me.
I don't want to open up
something and be like oh fuck--
- [Sam] Yeah, it aint broke.
- Yeah, like don't fix, yeah.
But if I wasn't mentally happy
I'm open for everything,
everything's in play.
- Have you heard of MDMA therapy?
- No.
- I think it's awesome.
Tucker Max, he's one of our investors,
because I go to therapy and I
used to take antidepressants.
He was like, "Dude, do this."
I've been on this medication for years
and I did this thing, I feel way better.
- Anything that helps
people get off medication
is something intuitively in my gut,
I'm not a doctor, I don't know,
like I'm sure there's plenty
of medicines that matter
but I'm always pumped knowing enough about
the business of Pharma in America,
I'm always pumped if people
can find a different way.
But back to psychedelics.
And sexual experimentation,
like what you're seeing right
now is a mature practical
version of what you saw in the 60s
and I think it's a game of stigma.
- What's an example of that?
- I think when I think about
my friends in Silicon Valley
who talk about psychedelics
and things of that nature
inevitably in that same dinner
it gets into alternative
sexual relationships,
open marriages in a more progressive way
than open marriages.
- I don't think I could never do that.
- Yeah, it's not for me either
but I don't like imposing my,
like what I think makes me
successful in these talks
is I never impose my will or opinion
on what will happen.
All my friends that are like fuck,
I got TikTok wrong.
And whether TikTok
disappears tomorrow or not,
there's incredible money being made
in the TikTok infrastructure
and that's what we're talking about,
business in this narrow way.
And they're like why are you always right?
I'm like because I
don't impose my opinion.
Because I'm talking to
these inner circle friends.
I'm like you said it was stupid for you.
You said that because you're insecure.
You have 800,000 followers on Instagram
and you don't want to start over.
You're doing what Tila Tequila
and Dane Cook did with MySpace.
You're doing what all
my homies on Twitter did
about Instagram.
You now are doing that to Instagram.
You're so set in your
thing and you've got clout
you don't want the world to reset.
I only want the world to reset
because I don't actually value my clout,
I value learnings and impact.
It's a huge deal so
psychedelics real quick
to finish yourself and then
jump in for your helps,
psychedelics stigma is gonna go away,
which is then gonna make people
feel comfortable to do it
and I have a very deep intuitive feeling
that is the medicine
or whatever the fuck you want to call it
that's gonna help a fuckload of people
who have not been able to find
their alternative in Advil
or in therapy or in much
harder core medicine
and that excites the shit out of me.
I want way more happiness in the world.
- Do we have time for one more or no?
- Go ahead, go ahead.
- Is there anything else
that's exciting you?
- DTC sports cards.
It's funny we've talked about it,
live events, DTC, and sports cards.
Practical DTC 'cause it's there,
but you can't take funding,
10 years not 10 minutes.
Sports cards I'm obsessed.
Live events I'm obsessed.
- For the DDC is there
any particular products
your fascinated?--
- Every single thing
that's sold in a store
is vulnerable to DDC.
- What I like to do is just
look at Procter & Gamble,
everything they sell, you
just throw a dart at it.
- Better than that and I like what you did
'cause Proctor's the leader
but like take it all.
Anything that's sold in a store--
- Target, just walk around Target.
- Anything and that then
tells every entrepreneur
because I know a lot
are listening right now,
sell what you love.
Like if you love blueberry jam,
fucking make that brand.
Back to you saying it's easy.
It has never been easier to be like
I love peanut butter and jelly for real,
for real I love it.
It's never been easier on earth
and I mean the delta is
like a billion to zero
on starting a peanut
butter and jelly brand
if you take a 10 year window.
If you take a 10 year window,
let me tell you real life
instead of this VC shit
and I know we're late but
fucking it, I'm pumped right now.
If you sell dumb shit in your house,
I don't have money Gary,
good you have stuff in your house.
You're like most Americans have stuff.
Even like people that
aren't making a lot of money
have fucking stuff.
- At least a thousand dollars of crap.
- Yes.
And if you don't, I'll teach
you and I keep teaching people
I'll teach you how to take 30 bucks
and turn into a thousand.
I fucking did in Trash Talk episode three.
It was called $20 of Olympic
pins for over a thousand.
Real-life, real talk.
Do you have the humility
to go garage saleing?
That's the question.
Do you have humility to go to dollar store
and walk out and while
everybody is at that Whole Foods
and sees you walking out with
bags from a dollar store,
people don't like judgment.
Do you have the humility
when you don't have a car
to go pick up something on Craigslist
and take the fucking bus and
sit with a lamp on your lap.
- Why wouldn't you want to
do that, that sounds fun.
- Because it's easier for
people mentally to complain
and blame than to take on accountability.
Accountable as fuck, tell 'em
I wanted this afternoon, Alex.
So nonetheless, if you
can get 20,000 bucks
by eating shit for a year and grinding
then you can then take that $20,000
to develop early stage peanut
butter and jelly brand,
early stage Instagram and TikTok ads,
and early stage, early stage, early stage.
AKA 10 years but in 10 years if you're 32,
could you imagine being
able to quit your job at 42
that you fucking hate and are dying inside
and do a business around
your singular thing,
your singular thing.
I'm talking, everybody needs to hear this,
this is "Crush It" 2008.
I was right, it's real.
Like people are still not doing it.
Fuck where you see the opportunity
because you read The Hustle and Trends
and you're like fuck, that's great.
And by the way you might be like me.
By the way me, I'm a business nerd,
I can get fired up about anything.
- Yeah, we just have to
nerd out on that stuff.
- Right but if you're
fucking hardcore toothpaste,
like you like it.
You like buy different brands,
you're intrigued by it,
it's vulnerable.
If you're like hardcore
skiing and video work
like go become the person
that fucking does
content on ski mountains.
It's real, it's fucking real.
But you have to think of it in 10 years
because anybody who thinks it's real
thinks you have to raise money.
Everybody thinks you
have to raise money now.
It's fucking broke bro.
- It's never been cheaper,
maybe if you live in San Francisco
but I always tell people,
move to New Mexico.
- So don't live in fucking San Francisco.
- [Sam] Go to New Mexico, go to Missouri.
- That's right bro, no for real.
- When BuzzFeed and Vox
were doing their thing
I was tweeting and I was like,
move your offices to St.
Louis, you'll be profitable.
- It's true.
Anyway bro, I really
appreciate you doing this show.
- Thank you for having me.
We have The Hustle and Trends and all that
but we also have this cool podcast that,
I was talking to your guy.
We're gonna be close and
beating you in the numbers,
that's my goal.
- Makes me happy.
- No, I'm just giving you a hard time.
- No, not on a hard
time, on some real shit.
Kobe Bryant was the most
competitive iconic figure
in our culture and when he
tweeted a congratulation,
his last tweet couldn't be more symbolic.
- [Sam] To Lebron.
- That's right and that's who I am.
Nothing makes me happier than
when entrepreneurs on merit
out work, out succeed me,
'cause that's the game.
Either you love the game or you don't.
- So these last five minutes
when we were just riffing
on interesting opportunities
what we do is we just research all of them
and we just riff on them
and we have experts come in sometimes.
It's called My First Million.
If you're in San Francisco
and ever want to come on it
like I said, similar reach
as this, come and do it.
- I'm happy to do it,
thanks for being on.
- Thanks for having me.